usually I don't like talking stuff but
it's kind of stronger than ever and
Quarantine has really brought us
together what we've come out noticing is
that we're super common and we both
actually never finished Naruto so we're
trying to watch through the entirety of
all 500 episodes I've even started doing
situps which is insane
thank you so much for taking time out of
your social distancing to chat about
your new comic book series sun-eater I'm
so excited for fans to experience that
you've been giving us little teases your
lovely girl Barbara posted on Instagram
how proud she is what was her reaction
when she finally got to read it for the
first time since we first started dating
and I I mean literally first off she was
asking me what I was doing in China and
I said I was writing something as well
as working out there and she said what
are you writing and I sent it to her
before we had really begun our
relationship and so she's seen the
progression of this series all the way
through and is a huge huge supporter and
not only that but a voice for which I
can bounce ideas off of and hear
objectively from someone kind of outside
of this world but empathizes with it how
this comes across or what might need to
change so she's a huge supporter and I
really don't think that I could have
done it without her and I would say
arguably more so than anyone else a lot
of the characters in there are insights
that we've talked about myself and her
and I've actually written a character
that has a lot of her own insights
inside of it too
but don't tell her that Oh what does she
know that I haven't told her straight up
but when we do readings
she needs that character so that's nice
that's really special when do you think
she's gonna find out her will you
eventually tell her well if she's
listening through the door right now she
might nap no I'll tell her at some point
maybe when it's dawn minutes oh that's
so special and that this is kind of
evolved as your relationship has
progressed like what a special thing oh
I agree but also you know I'll say that
I think the nature of this story needed
to evolve in a way where I was
interacting with mine
and so I Sagas what this is based off of
either it's a tale of boasted heroism
and it's just you know super heavy metal
right or there to some degree cautionary
like them all and that's arguably not a
saga per se but it's with the same sort
of styles but there ways to live your
life cautionary tales things of that
sort and so I wanted to kind of in you a
little bit of all of that it has been
quite the quarantine for you when you
last checked in with you it was at the
end of March and you're promoting banana
split now here we are full two months
later so here's a little quarantine
check and how you do until it um well I
like to stay busy as you can probably
tell
I've been hunkering down I think the
best part that I've encountered so far
of my own isolation with Barbara is the
amount of anime that we've watched it
has given me a lot of influence even on
my own writings but suffice to say I
think everyone's still kind of managing
and I thought before quarantine that I
could stay inside and play video games
and watch TV indefinitely no questions
asked I can sit on my ass and watch that
stuff for as many hours as it took and I
have started to feel stir crazy too
I'm looking for ways I've even started
doing situps which is insane
anyone who knows me knows that's too far
over the walk delenn are you okay I know
a little bit but what have you barber
been binging on that anime list or just
in general have you found any new
favorite yeah well we've been watching
this one that we're both crazy about
called Kaguya sama love is more which
sounds really nerdy and it dries cool
it's an amazing amazing anime that's a
super fun drama about these high school
students who are in this Academy where
they can't confess their love to each
other but because they're both kind of
Kanaya being they're trying to convince
to confess first and then we're in love
with each other and it's so funny it's
so enjoyable to watch so we've been
obsessed with that one and we both
actually never finished Naruto so we're
trying to watch through the entirety of
all 500 episodes that is a huge feat to
accomplish it's Herculean there's a lot
of filler
we've been hurting out most of it though
has there been anything new that you've
learned about Barbara over these past
few months social distancing together I
know that this is exciting for you guys
because we both travel so often and with
your jobs you really got to spend so
much time together and have you
discovered anything this is definitely
the most amount of time in one place
we've been allowed to stay with each
other we went into it with like some
ground rules and a little bit of
hesitancy as anybody would right yeah
it's been completely fine what we've
come out noticing is that we're super
camp and we know when to give each other
space we know when the other needs space
we've already divided labor around the
house in certain ways and the right
division there's things we do in the
morning there's things we do night and
so I think a relationship this is too
much information is stronger than ever
usually I don't like to talk about
relationship stuff but it's kind of
stronger than ever
and Quarantine has really brought us
together that's really amazing so it's
nice yeah I think that very often you
know I'll hear the opposite recently and
we just kind of look at each other and
we're like well I'm really thankful I
feel like if you can survive or pandemic
together then you're meant to be right
looking at cabins and stuff wish
wishfully in the future we're looking at
a lot of different stuff like that the
one thing I will say is that we do have
a moment where we almost broke down and
adopted I will be that voice if I have
to make the hard decisions I will say
don't think it's time I feel like this
is me and my boyfriend what we're doing
right now we go outside I'm like blue
and he's like no okay
yeah that's been the dangerous thing
we've looked outside on our balcony and
seeing a lot of cute puppies
it's a lot of cute puppies having about
right now and that's dangerous have a
lovely day and I'll Barbara about the
character she's gonna find out oh she
just heard you on the couch action
goodbye see you later
[Music]